This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the
psychology of our 20s. Thank you for joining us. And thank you to begin to all of you for the support you have shown the announcement of my debut book, Person in Progress, which comes out in April 2025. It has blown me away. Truly, how many of you have pre-ordered and sent me such lovely messages. And if you want to be one of the first people to get your hands on a copy and read it, you can find the link in the episode description. Even if you just want to check out the cover, it's all there. I just couldn't start the episode without acknowledging the love and the generosity and all the kindness that you have shown me. But this week, we are not talking about the book or anything close to it. I'm going to move on and dive into our topic today because,
wow, all of you have wanted to hear about it for a while. And you have been so patient with me as I kept promising it. We're finally there. We are going to. going to be talking about the psychology of the middle child. So late last year, I believe, I did an episode on what it's like to be the eldest daughter and so many of you related. So many of you were like, yeah, I totally agree. That is me to a tea. But another huge number of you also said, you know, what about us middle children? What if I'm the middle child and the eldest daughter? Because, you know, I have an older brother or I have brothers, where do I sit? Well, after months of requests, I finally get to give you the answers
you're looking for. What is middle child syndrome? How are middle children built differently? How are they raised differently? What is their psychology? What are their insecurities, their inner emotional lives and personalities like, you know, the eldest and the youngest of a family, they always get so much attention because they like bookmark the family, system, like they bookmark, like, the family unit. And, you know, the middle child is never really made to feel special. But today, we're going to put that spotlight on them and spend the next 30, 40 minutes, just focusing on middle children, justice for the middle children, the chameleons of the
family, the forgotten children. What does psychology and birth order theory say about this group of people? And how is your personality influenced by this? you know, seemingly arbitrary position in the family because a lot of the research and a lot of the studies would say that it is greatly influenced by it. So without further ado, there is so much to talk about quite genuinely, so many studies, so many historical theories, so many lived experiences from some of you guys, some of the listeners who are middle children. I used to always think that only eldest children and only children listen to the podcast, you guys definitely
proved me wrong. So, for my middle children or for those who are curious, buckle in, sit down, let us break down, the very intricate, very interesting psychology of the middle child. The idea that where you are born in the family, whether that is first born, middle, youngest, the idea that that will somehow influence your personality and how you grow up, it is supported and actually it was first put forward by something called Burmerell. order theory. You've probably heard about it. You've probably seen it on TikTok, on Instagram. It's been doing the rounds. But this theory is really what we need to begin the episode with, because it is the tree from which all of our assumptions, our thoughts, our feelings, our ideas about middle
children tend to come from. You know, it comes from the theory, but that theory also comes from experience, from what we typically see of the middle child. So birth order theory, was developed by a very famous psychotherapist called Alfred Adler. You probably don't know his name. Maybe you do. I shouldn't assume. But even if you don't know his name, you definitely know some of his work. So he originated the term inferiority complex, if you've heard of that one.
He was also one of the first psychotherapists to actually start studying personality. He was also, and I don't know if you are familiar with this, idea. He was the person who proposed that in life. The three major focuses for us are love, friendship and work. So if you know that famous equation, that is Dr. Alfred Adler. And he is also the one who birth-originated birth order theory. So he's kind of everywhere in modern psychology. Like if you go digging long and deep enough, you will find some link back to him. And during that work on personality that we were speaking about, he observed a lot of people and he began to see this pattern between his participants and his studies whereby people who were born into the same
position in the family based on their birth order seemed quite similar. And they adopted many of the same traits, even when he controlled for things like income, like country of birth, like the education of the parents. You know, if you were the eldest, that made you a certain person. If you were one of the middle children or a second child, as he called back then, that also influenced you, as did your role as a youngest child or an only child. So he basically developed this theory that each family is like a constellation. And when you were born, you are given a specific location or position in that constellation that will inform how you behave, how outgoing you are, how anxious you are, confident, smart, ambitious you are, based on kind of how, you know,
the constellation and the solar system work based on where the sun is, based on how you rotate the other planets, i.e. your siblings, i.e. your parents. Basically, and this is the major controversy with birth order theory, he basically says, and said at the time, if you give me an individual and you tell me where they were born in their family, I could tell you exactly what kind of person they are. I can tell you what grades they're getting. I can tell you what their love life is like. I can tell you how ambitious they are, how anxious they are, how close they are with their family. Pretty big call to make. And I will say in recent years, as we've developed much more robust experimental research techniques, there are elements of this theory
that have not withstood the test of time, especially as it relates to grand assumptions about intelligence and success, and, you know, is your marriage going to work out based on whether you're the eldest or the middle or the youngest? Also, you know, we are a lot more informed around gender and gender diversity and what it means to be someone who is perhaps non-binary. You know, it used to very much be daughters, sons, eldest, youngest, middle. we now know that there are also blended families and it mixes and it matches. So the theory, you know, we need to take it with a grain of salt. We need to take what we can from it and leave some of
the outdated parts of it behind. And it does still offer a very interesting way of seeing how children are perhaps treated differently in the family ecosystem. And there is no denying. I think that, you know, family dynamics definitely shape personality. and that also includes birth order because children are treated differently by their parents based on what position they take in the family and sibling dynamic. Eldest children, as we know, are stereotypically given a lot of responsibility. They're very ambitious. They want to take control of everything.
the outdated parts of it behind. And it does still offer a very interesting way of seeing how children are perhaps treated differently in the family ecosystem. And there is no denying. I think that, you://family dynamics definitely shape personality. and that also includes birth order because children are treated differently by their parents based on what position they take in the family and sibling dynamic. Eldest children, as we know, are stereotypically given a lot of responsibility. They're very ambitious. They want to take control of everything.
The youngest child is often quite doted on. They're the baby. And, well, the middle child, the middle child is, what we're here to talk about today. So the only reason I offer this caveat that perhaps Adler's original theory is a little bit outdated is just so that you know it's not going to apply to everyone, especially since the original findings were based on cross-sectional data and, you know, in the modern age, we really want more of that longitudinal data. That's really what would be best for answering questions around birth order theory. You know, if you followed people across their
The youngest child is often quite doted on. They're the baby. And, well, the middle child, the middle child is, what we're here to talk about today. So the only reason I offer this caveat that perhaps Adler's original theory is a little bit outdated is just so that you know it's not going to apply to everyone, especially since the original findings were based on cross-sectional data and, you://in the modern age, we really want more of that longitudinal data. That's really what would be best for answering questions around birth order theory. You know, if you followed people across their
life and you saw how that changed. That is so nerdy and boring and we don't need to get into the statistical and experimental details. But the biggest complaint I always get, anytime I talk about birth order theory is like, that doesn't apply to me. Like, that's not me. That's, that's fine. That's totally okay. In fact, it's normal for theories to not apply to everyone. That's why we need to continue to test them, right? But what Adler did typically find was that elders children were very ambitious. They felt a real sense of responsibility. They were maybe a bit entitled, a bit anxious, but very focused, very well behaved. They also tended to be friends with other eldest children. Elders' daughters are their own unique kettle of
fish. You can listen to episode 147 on that, if you want to know about that specifically. And then we had, you know, the youngest children. They tended to be very sociable, extroverted, a little bit, maybe attention seeking. They also tend to get away with more, be rural, challenge, and challenges. Some might say they're a little bit spoiled as well because they are the baby of the family. I was talking to my friend, Steph, about this. And she is the youngest child. And she was explaining to me, she was like, well, you know, by the time I was 14, 15, 16, all my siblings had like moved out. So, you know, my parents had more money and more resources to spoil me. And, you know, they were kind of tired at that stage of, like, you know, applying all the rules. They'd become a lot.
more slack, less chores, more freedom. She kind of got away with a little bit more. You know, I think a lot of parents start out being like, these are the kinds of people and parents were going to be, and we're going to have no screens, that we're going to have strict rules. Now children will behave and they will learn manners and we have a, you know, a lot of expectations. But, you know, surely you get tired. You know, the eldest child copses the most of it, then the middle child, the middle children, I should say. And the youngest child, by the time we get around that, that parents get tired, they can't be bothered. You know, I found that with my little sister as well, like not to call her out.
more slack, less chores, more freedom. She kind of got away with a little bit more. You know, I think a lot of parents start out being like, these are the kinds of people and parents were going to be, and we're going to have no screens, that we're going to have strict rules. Now children will behave and they will learn manners and we have a, you://a lot of expectations. But, you know, surely you get tired. You know, the eldest child copses the most of it, then the middle child, the middle children, I should say. And the youngest child, by the time we get around that, that parents get tired, they can't be bothered. You know, I found that with my little sister as well, like not to call her out.
Like, there are a lot more slack. I could also go into what this dynamic looks like for only children being both the eldest, middle and youngest. That is for another time. Where does this leave the middle child, knowing what the eldest child and the youngest children tend to look like? What do the middle children look like? Well, they are literally stuck in the middle.
They are stuck in between the ambitious, responsible eldest and the charming spoilt youngest. And they can end up feeling left out, neglected, forgotten about because they aren't the bookend children. You know, it's also important to note. They also are the only sibling who has to share their birth position with someone else. What do I mean by that is that you can only have one eldest and you can only have one youngest, But you can have two, three, four, I don't know, let's get crazy here, five middle children. So not even their birth order of their birth position is their own. Sometimes middle children even have to share the middle position.
So that is why they're sometimes referred to as like the forgotten child of the family, whether you agree with that description or that's your experience or not. It's really led to this creation of this term called middle child syndrome. It's not a clinical disorder. You know, you can't go to a psychologist and ask for diagnosis and a script and some medication, but it basically explains a pattern of feelings and behaviors reflected by the middle child. And I'm going to start with the positives here. What makes the middle child so different in a good way and so unique and something to be celebrated?
Well, the middle child is often highly independent and flexible. You know, they're not too fuss about getting their own way because they'll kind of make their own way. They're very much used to that. Their position as the middle child means that they, you know, haven't had those first through, you know, first few years being an only child like the eldest, but they aren't the baby like the youngest. They aren't maybe given special treatment. So they kind of get used to being tucked away in the middle and not getting their own way.
my sister is like this 100,000 percent. She was so accommodating. And I do think it's because she is a middle child. You know, when we were kids, we used to, like my parents made such a big deal of making sure that Ellie, who is my sister, was allowed to make decisions. We had Ellie days or Ellie decisions where Ellie got to choose what we did. Ellie got to choose what we ate because so often she'd kind of just coast under the radar. Like she wasn't going to be loud and annoying about not getting.
her own way. And so 99% of the time she didn't. So they would really be quite intentional with making sure that just because she was the most cooperative, she didn't have to always be the one who missed out. Middle children are also very diplomatic. They're always resolving the tensions or the fights between their siblings or between their parents and their siblings, which is, as we know, sometimes a form of parentification. The child takes on the role, the emotional. The emotional. The emotional role of the parent. A child should not be, you know, mediating or resolving conflict at any point in a family. That is the role of the parent. That is their duty. So often, you know, we tend to think of the eldest child or the eldest daughter being parentified. Sometimes in these instances
when there is, you know, it's more emotionally complex and you need someone to see both sides. You need someone to call the shots. The middle child is the one who does it. I, often think that the reason they turn out to be such mediators is because they can see both sides very well, because they're often the ones who have the least amount of age difference. You know, the eldest and the youngest have the largest age difference. The middle child is kind of often developmentally or, you know, age-wise, smack bang in the middle. You know, they can, they have maybe more of the maturity than the youngest, but they have more of the empathy for the current experience than the eldest. So that is something that we typically see. Also, they're very loyal as one article
from psychology today, which is I quote it all the time. I love psychology today. This is what this article said. They're very, very loyal. And, you know, this second part is up for debate. They are also typically family oriented. Now, why is this up for debate? It used to be that people thought that middle children weren't very family oriented. As soon as they kind of got the opportunity to leave out they went. They didn't, you know, they were the ones who went off on their own, which is kind of true. They are very independent. But a 2009 study I was reading actually suggests that they still really care for the family
and they value family and they put lots into the family. They may actually just have better boundaries or they are like. less dependent on their family than the eldest or the youngest. And so from the outside, it looks like they don't care. It looks like that isn't a priority for them. No, not true. It's just that it looks different. They also may be really protective of their relationships outside of the family, which brings me to like what I would call a neutral trait of the middle sibling. They can be quite secretive, especially about their private life, you know, who they're dating, who they're friends with, their problems. You know, they don't want to make too much noise, is I guess,
kind of what I'm saying. Now, this part about being secretive towards their problems, that bears examining, because this is actually not very psychologically healthy. It's not something that we want to see or we want to encourage in any child or a middle child, whoever it is. You know, you have never heard someone say, you know, I pushed all my feelings down and I suppressed it and I stayed silent and now I feel so much better. No, we hear people say, I feel better when I open up. I feel better when I share. I feel better when I, you know, have community around me who understands what I'm going through. So the fact that middle children are more likely to withdraw and isolate can at times be quite worrying. this is why this very tendency to withdraw isolate be quite secretive, cooperative.
This is why people call middle children the chameleons. They blend in, they don't stand out. They are very, I guess that's the best way to put it. They don't stand out, right? And the best way to show this, or the best example of this that I've seen in the research, was actually a paper from the 80s. and it examined gifted children and birth order theory. So basically what the paper wanted to find out was,
you know, is the eldest always going to be the gifted child or the youngest? Like, does birth order determine whether you've got some specialness about you? And they invited people, parents, to bring in their supposedly gifted children. And all of them were bringing in their eldest children. A huge majority were. But actually when they went to test these children, they also said to the parents, well, you know, we'll give you a discount if you bring in your middle child, your youngest child. We just want to do it, you know, with all of them. Chances are you could have multiple gifted children. And the parents would be like, no, no, no, no, no. Like our middle child is so, you know, so easygoing. Like they're lovely, they're great, but like they're not, they're not a standout. You know, they're not standing out in academics. They're not standing out in sports or arts. They're not that talented. But when they'd come in for testing, the doctors, the professors, the teachers, whoever was administering the tests, they often found that actually these middle children, even the youngest
children and the eldest children, they all had the same, relatively the same intelligence, the same EQ, the same level of talent. But the middle child blended in. The middle child did not stand out and the middle child did not have the same wild expectations that the eldest or the youngest might be accustomed to experiencing. You know, by the end of this experiment, they had 50 different sibling pairs. Out of that 50, 42 of them, so comparing eldest and middle, 42 of them were almost identical in terms of all these objective measures for giftedness.
But on the outside, the eldest was just a lot more loud about it. and maybe the parents were expecting them to be the talented one. And so they were more likely to kind of put the tiara, put the crown on them and say, great, you're the one that we're choosing. You're the gifted one. Remember, these parents were the ones bringing in these kids, and a lot of the time they weren't bringing in the middle children.
So they're kind of seen differently, despite objectively being the same, they're seen differently in the family, which may also cause them to act. act differently. It could be a self-fulfilling prophecy. The other explanation for this, and this is just something that I personally think it wasn't in the paper, I think that the middle child, like, sees how the eldest child is treated and is like, that is way too much pressure. Like, I, that stress does not look fun. That does not look enjoyable. I'm just going to blend in,
because I just want to cruise. Like, my eldest sibling looks super stressed. doesn't look happy. I'm going to go under the radar. I'm going to maybe opt out of that situation. Or, or another explanation is they think, well, they can't be, they can only be room for one. They can't be room for two. So I'm just going to chill. I'm going to do something else. Those are like two of the thoughts that I kind of have about this. And it may also explain why sometimes the middle child goes in the opposite direction of their older brother or sister in terms of personality and in terms of how they express that personality. So I'm going to bring up another study. Guys, I'm full of studies today. I've got so much research to share with you. And this one
actually came from some researchers at MIT. And what they found was that, you know, middle sons in particular, they were more likely to be the black sheep of the family compared to eldest sons, eldest daughters, youngest sons, the middle child, specifically the middle sons, they were the thumb that kind of stuck out. So this research was conducted in 2017, semi-recently, on the cusp. And the team of researchers collected and analyzed data from thousands of sibling groups in the United States and in Denmark, and they found that the middle son, if there was a middle son, was 25 to 40 percent times more likely to have problems with discipline, getting told off at school, they were more likely to have been suspended, to be seen as
a bit rebellious, or to even end up in jail. The explanation that was given by the head researcher in which we see repeated quite frequently when it comes to speaking about the middle child, they just don't get the same amount of undivided attention as the eldest or the youngest. And perhaps for boys in particular, they compensate for that by acting out. They really want that attention, they want to be cared for. And if they can't get that care organically, they can get it through being rebellious because people have to look at them. I think that that is a very interesting explanation that comes up again and again and again.
The middle child is overlooked. They're dominated by the stronger siblings. They slip through the cracks. And that means they have to carve out their identity in any way that they can. Obviously, I think a big long-term consequence of that is a lot of resentment. Any one of us who has siblings, we know that when you're young, everything is always a competition. and when it's exaggerated by this other complex aspect to the equation of being the middle child versus the eldest or the youngest, it can just become a bigger fire.
You can just get out of hand. There are some exceptions and distinctions as with everything in life. And one of my favorite things that I've learned about birth order theory from researching it all these years is that middle child syndrome in particular actually becomes less present. announced, the bigger the age gap is between siblings because they have time to really develop and solidify their own unique identity. It's not, you know, superseded by that of their eldest sibling or youngest siblings. So say, for example, you have an age gap of five years compared to one year. So, you know, like the kids are seven and twelve and seventeen or seven and eleven and fifteen or whatever it is, that is preferable to kids that are like one, three and four or something like that
because they're at different developmental periods. So the parents can do different activities with them. They don't have their hands as full. And that really seems to alleviate the middle child syndrome that we're speaking about here. Also, gender plays a role because you can be the middle child, but also the eldest daughter. You know, even if you're not the eldest child, you may be the oldest daughter as the middle child and you still may be forced to take on the maturity, the daughters are expected to and the responsibility, and you may feel like you need to almost be a parent for your older sibling, your older brother, even though you're younger. So there is these interactions. They definitely need more research on this. I don't think I've even come across
a study about this, mainly because I think being an eldest daughter, perhaps supersedes being in middle child, but they would definitely interact in terms of the double burden of not only needing to be responsible for your male siblings and for your younger siblings, but then also expecting to be that extra bit cooperative and perhaps being that extra bit ignored by the family. So just something to think of, regardless, we can, I think we can see and we can claim that there is a shared experience within middle children. There are things that are very, very similar that are common, that people could relate to one another about. What I want to answer next is what happens with this experience when we're adults. How does this kind of follow us through
our adult lives, even when we're not a child anymore, even when we're not around our siblings all the time, even when this middle child syndrome is not being enforced and is not actively being placed upon us, it still impacts our personality. So we're going to talk about that and also how to make sense of some of these experiences, how to maybe even let go of some of the resentment to do with middle child syndrome after this short break. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with
writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years
所以我也开始看出其中有一条贯穿的线索了。我们目前也把关于艾滋病的话题提上了日程。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是最重要的年份之一
for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, in this month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes
是美国历史上对黑人而言至关重要的一年。欢迎在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方回看它。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，在这一个月里，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多出色嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时
when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you're you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要？你们当好人是因为恐惧吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是出于本心去当一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，由我吉尔·盖恩斯带你一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这就开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改过测试一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marangini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男性，格雷格·阿莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被因欺诈罪起诉。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. One of the principles behind ideas like reparenting, in a child healing, age regression therapy, any number of those methods, is that the experiences you have as a child are reflected in your adult personality. People, you know, of course we change over the course of our lives based on relationships, based on place, based on experiences, context. But the roles that we adopt as children, be that gender roles, social roles or family roles, they tend to really leave a mark. Think about how when you're a child, you were taught to be polite, you were taught to respect your
在亚利桑那州实现正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。像重新养育、内小孩疗愈、年龄回归疗法等理念背后的原则之一，就是你在童年时期的经历会反映在你的成年人格中。人们，当然，我们在一生中会根据关系、根据地点、根据经历、背景而改变。但是我们在童年中扮演的角色，无论是性别角色、社会角色还是家庭角色，它们往往真的会留下深刻的印记。想想当你还是个孩子的时候，你如何被教导要有礼貌，如何被教导要尊重
elders to not, you know, I don't know, cut in line. It feels very unnatural to go against that, right? It carries with us. The same goes for how we have been conditioned to act in the family and then outside of the family. In the case of birth order or being the middle. child. If you constantly had to take on the role of a mediator, peacemaker, you were the cooperative one and you took on that role with your siblings and with your family, as you grow up, this can be transferred to other relationships, into your friendships, into your role in the workplace, who you date,
长辈，不要，你知道的，不要插队。违背这些感觉很不自然，对吧？它会伴随着我们。我们在家庭中以及家庭之外被训练的行为方式也是如此。就出生顺序或作为中间的孩子而言。如果你不得不经常扮演调解员、和平缔造者的角色，你是那个懂得合作的人，并且你在兄弟姐妹和家庭中扮演了那个角色，随着你长大，这可以转移到其他关系中，转移到你的友谊中，转移到你在职场中的角色，你和谁约会，
how you relate to them. You might find it really hard to shake this deep sense that you can make everyone get along the way that you always did with your sisters or your brothers or your parents even you know i have one friend who's a middle child who was like you know when i met my partner and in early relationships i really had to learn that i did not have to manage the conflict i was not responsible for always having a timeline for the conflict for finding a solution i didn't have to keep harmony between us or even between him and his siblings you know, a middle children may have that natural conflict aversion. Like, you know, I can't deal with these heightened emotions. I'm just going to, let's just move on. I don't want to deal with this.
你如何与他们相处。你可能会发现很难摆脱这种深深的感觉，即你可以让每个人都合得来，就像你以前对你的姐妹、兄弟甚至父母所做的那样。你知道，我有一个身为中间孩子的明友，他曾说：“你知道，当我遇到伴侣时，在早期的恋爱关系中，我真的必须学会，我不必去处理冲突，我不必对总是为冲突设定时间表、寻找解决方案负有责任，我不需要在我们之间甚至在他和他的兄弟姐妹之间保持和谐。”你知道，中间的孩子可能会有这种天生的回避冲突的倾向。就像，“你知道，我无法处理这些高涨的情绪。我只是，我们继续前进吧。我不想处理这个。”
I'm just going to pull back, keep silent in these circumstances. I'm just going to blend in. In another way, adult middle children are often really great at negotiating. They're really able to bring about consensus without kind of being pulled into the flurry of emotions because they are so agreeable by nature. You know what? I would love to do a PhD on if I ever get the chance. And I've said this for a long time. I would love to see if you could find like a correlation between birth order and the careers that people choose. Like whether they are analytical careers or creative careers, what kind of skills are required and like chart our tendency towards certain categories of careers or professions based on like youngest middle eldest kids. I get a bunch of families with, I don't know, three, four, five siblings.
我只是会退缩，在这些情况下保持沉默。我只会融入其中。在另一方面，成年的中间孩子通常非常擅长谈判。他们确实能够在不被卷入情绪风暴的情况下达成共识，因为他们天生就很好相处。你知道吗？如果有机会的话，我很乐做一项关于这个的博士研究。我这样说已经很久了。我很想看看你是否能发现出生顺序与人们选择的职业之间存在某种关联。比如它们是分析型职业还是创意型职业，需要什么样的技能，以及根据最小的、中间的、最大的孩子来绘制我们对某些职业类别或职业的倾向图。我找来一群家庭，拥有，我不知道，三个、四个、五个兄弟姐妹。
and be like, where did you end up? What are you doing? And is there like similarities? Can we find a pattern? Like, it would be so fascinating because if we were like to take the profile laid out of the middle child, like the stereotypical middle child and disregard any of the nuances, what would they be? And I feel like they'd be great at HR. They'd be a great social worker or a teacher. They'd be great in PR, public relations, even like customer service or a journalist. The journalist one in particular, I think, would be good because they can be very diplomatic and independent and maybe not stand out. If you're doing like a big scandalous story on like corruption, you can be a little bit secretive, like we said before, a little bit sly. Definitely going off track here, but, you know,
然后问：“你们最后都在哪里？你们在做什么？是否存在相似之处？我们能找到某种模式吗？”这将会非常迷人，因为如果我们采用中间孩子的概况，比如刻板印象中的中间孩子并抛开所有细微差别，他们会是什么样的人？我觉得他们会非常适合人力资源工作。他们会成为出色的社工或老师。他们在公关、公共关系领域也会很出色，甚至在客服或记者行业也是如此。特别是记者那一项，我觉得会很好，因为他们可以非常外交且独立，或许不会太显眼。如果你要做一篇关于腐败的大型丑闻报道，你可以表现得稍微隐秘一点，就像我们之前说的，稍微有点狡猾。这里绝对有点偏离主题了，但是，你知道，
if the elders are quite dominant, the youngest is a bit of tension seeking and charismatic and the middle chart is cooperative and is a little bit like sneaky, where does that kind of lead them in terms of their career? Obviously, it's probably unlikely, A, that I'm ever going to do that study, but B, that if I were to do that study, I would find anything concrete because with something like career, personality of which personality is only mildly informed by birth order, like, that's only a small contribution. You have so many other things. But that's like the thing with psychology, right? Even if you can't have one answer, it can give you a clue, it can give you hints. And so although other factors like finances, like even gender roles or your values or your
如果长辈相当强势，最小的孩子有点寻求关注且富有魅力，而中间的孩子善于合作且有点鬼祟，这在他们的职业生涯方面会引导他们走向何方？显然，这可能不太可能，第一，我永远不会去做那个研究；第二，如果我要做那个研究，我也不会发现任何具体的东西，因为对于像职业这样由人格塑造的东西——而人格仅在很小程度上受到出生顺序的影响，也就是说，那只是一个很小的贡献。你还有很多其他的事情。但这就是心理学的问题所在，对吧？即使你无法得到一个答案，它也可以给你提供线索，给你提供暗示。因此，尽管其他因素，比如财务，甚至性别角色，或者是你的价值观，或者你的
dreams and your hobbies, that is also going to contribute to a career choice, much like personality, I would just find it really fascinating, like if we could just find something like research for research's sake. moving on though one thing that adult middle children do speak about a lot though is growing into an adult and finally realizing how overlooked they may have been as a child especially in a dysfunctional family dynamic in those dynamics when everybody is absolutely focused on themselves it is chaotic it is confusing it is wild it is unmanageable maybe it's a little bit toxic. Someone always has to lose out. And because the middle child made less of a fuss,
梦想和爱好，这也将对职业选择产生影响，就像个性一样，我只是觉得这会非常迷人，如果我们能找到一些为了研究而研究的东西。不过话又说回来，成年中间孩子经常谈论的一件事是，在长大成人后，终于意识到他们在童年时期可能被忽视了多少，尤其是在功能失调的家庭动力中。在那些动态中，当每个人都绝对专注于自己时，它是混乱的、令人困惑的、疯狂的、无法管理的，也许还有点有毒。总得有人做出牺牲。而由于中间孩子没有大惊小怪，
maybe it was always you. The resentment over those experiences can definitely grow over time, even if you were like, oh no, you know, there was never a problem. Maybe you turn 25, 26, 27. Maybe you start considering how you would raise your own kids and you were like, I don't think I would want them to feel the way that I did. I wouldn't want my child to, to feel like no one paid attention to them. I didn't, I don't want them to feel like they have to make adjustments for everyone else. Those moments can really push you into a place of introspection and anger. That's the big one. Anger that comes up years later is not uncommon. There can also be resentment, you know, not just towards your parents, your parents are normally going to be the first
也许那个人一直都是你。随着时间的推移，对那些经历的怨恨肯定会增长，即使你曾经说过：“哦，不，你知道的，从来没有过问题。”也许你到了25岁、26岁、27岁。也许你开始考虑你会如何抚养自己的孩子，然后你会想：“我不认为我会希望他们感受到我曾经感受过的那些。我不希望我的孩子去，去觉得没有人关注他们。我不希望他们觉得他们必须为了其他人做出调整。”这些时刻真的会把你推向一个内省和愤怒的地方。这是一个大问题。多年后出现的愤怒并不少见。也可能会有怨恨，你知道的，不仅仅是对你的父母，你的父母通常会是第一批
wants to get that, but also your siblings. Like, why, why did you, why were you treated like you were special? Why were you the golden child? Why, why couldn't I have been the golden child? Why did I just have to blend in? Why did you guys get to stand out? Why did you guys get spoiled? Why did you guys get to have more of a say as much as children, I guess, do have a say? That's the really interesting anger. And I would also say grief. and sadness sometimes that comes with being aware of how your past and your childhood and the role you played has shaped who you are as an adult and has maybe left a bit of an emotional mark on your personality. I think this is something that we do just need to come to terms with.
想要得到这个的人，还有你的兄弟姐妹。就像，为什么，为什么你，为什么你被当作特殊对待？为什么你是那个金童？为什么，为什么我就不能成为金童？为什么我只能融入其中？为什么你们能够脱颖而出？为什么你们能够被宠坏？为什么你们能拥有更多的话语权——尽管孩子们大概确实有话语权？这是非常有趣的愤怒。我还要说，伴随着意识到你的过去、你的童年以及你所扮演的角色如何塑造了现在的你，并在某种程度上在你的个性上留下了情感印记，而产生的那种悲伤和伤感。我认为这是我们需要坦然接受的事情。
There's no changing it. And hopefully we can release that bitterness for yourself. You know, that's something that you have to carry. You might feel bitter, angry to. someone else, but they're not carrying that feeling you are. It becomes your burden as much as you might feel that your parents or your siblings deserve to feel guilty or bad or you deserve recognition. Inevitably, that's going to take up more space in your mind than in their mind. And it can also lead to some pretty heavy thoughts, you know, thinking, you know, why wasn't I given more space in the family? Thinking, is it because I'm unlovable? Is it because I'm, boring is because of who I am, thinking, you know, is it because my parents didn't love me as much?
这是无法改变的。希望我们可以为自己释放那种苦涩。你知道，那是你必须承担的事情。你可能会对别人感到痛苦、愤怒，但他们并没有承载那种感觉，是你。它成了你的负担，尽管你可能觉得你的父母或兄弟姐妹应该感到内疚或糟糕，或者你值得得到认可。不可避免地，这会在你的大脑中占用比在他们的大脑中更多的空间。它还可能导致一些相当沉重的想法，你知道，你会想：“为什么我在家里没有得到更多的空间？”你会想：“是因为我不可爱吗？”是因为我很无聊，是因为我是谁吗？你会想：“是因为我的父母没有那么爱我吗？”
Now, that is what resentment loves to do. Resentment takes any thought you have and bundles it in with all the confusion and sometimes the hurt and the anger and it just makes it bigger and bigger and bigger, especially when you don't call out those thoughts, especially when you don't think about what another explanation could be. And maybe there isn't one. We're going to get to that in a second. What I need you to remember is three things. Three things, if you're feeling this type of way about who you are as a middle child, you are allowed to feel frustrated by the differential treatment between you and your siblings. That is okay, that is normal, to feel upset about it.
现在，这就是怨恨最喜欢做的事情。怨恨会把你脑海中的任何想法与所有的困惑、有时还有受伤和愤怒捆绑在一起，并让它变得越来越大，尤其是在你没有质疑那些想法的时候，尤其是在你没有思考可能还有什么其他解释的时候。也许根本没有。我们一会儿就会讲到这一点。我需要你记住三件事。三件事，如果你对作为中间孩子的自己有这种感觉，你被允许对你和你的兄弟姐妹之间受到的不同对待感到沮丧。这是可以的，这是正常的，为之感到难过也是正常的。
To feel maybe even jealous. You can feel sad for the experiences that you didn't feel like you got to have, because that was your childhood too, those were your opportunities as well. However, that cannot dictate the rest of your life story. Secondly, if it's any consolation, I think middle children honestly rock. Like, they are normally some of the best people I've ever met. You have some of the best traits, you know, compared to eldest children and youngest children, I will say the middle child has fewer negative traits and fewer idiosyncrasies than most. So if it's any consolation, and it doesn't have to be, I do think that you're probably pretty remarkable and you do get a good deal in terms
甚至会感到嫉妒。你会为那些你觉得自己没有得到的经历感到难过，因为那也是你的童年，那些也是你的机会。然而，这不能决定你余下的人生故事。其次，如果这能给你带来一些安慰的话，我觉得中间出生的孩子真的很棒。比如，他们通常是我见过的最好的人。你拥有一些最好的特质，你知道的，与长子和幼子相比，我要说的是，中间的孩子比大多数人拥有更少的负面特质和更少的怪癖。所以，如果这能给你带来一点安慰的话，而且这也并不是必须的，我确实认为你可能非常优秀，而且在某些方面
of how other people see you and how easy it is to get along with you and how fun you typically are and sociable. Finally, this final reminder, birth order is not everything. There is not one thing that defines someone fully. And family position is not deterministic. It is not a magic ball. It certainly is not something that will solely define you for all of the years to come. You can heal the parts of you that you feel you don't like because of where you are in the family. And you can also heal the parts of you that were resentful by engaging in some reparenting,
别人如何看你、你有多容易相处、你通常有多有趣以及多具有社交性，这些方面你都得到了很好的待遇。最后，最后一个提醒，出生顺序并非一切。没有什么单一的东西能完全定义一个人。家庭地位也不是决定论的。它不是一个魔法球。它当然不是那种会在未来所有岁月里唯一定义你的东西。你可以疗愈自己身上那些因为你在家庭中的位置而让你觉得不喜欢的部分。你还可以通过进行一些重新育儿，
reparenting yourself. So reparenting, we mentioned it at the top of this section. It is a therapeutic approach that involves nurturing and healing ourselves and our childhood selves by providing the care, the validation, the support and the attention that you may have felt was lacking in childhood. So for middle children who often feel very overlooked or like caught up in family dynamics, reparenting is particularly powerful. And it's particularly powerful when you provide yourself with the attention, like I said before, that you maybe didn't receive or when you allow yourself to be in control and to call the shots. And you don't always have to be the cooperative one.
对自己进行重新育儿，来疗愈那些曾经心怀怨恨的部分。所以，重新育儿，我们在本节开头提到过它。它是一种治疗方法，包括通过提供关爱、认可、支持和关注来滋养和疗愈我们自己以及我们内心的童年自我，而这些关爱、认可、支持和关注你可能会觉得在童年时是缺乏的。因此，对于经常感到被忽视或卷入家庭动态中的中间孩子来说，重新育儿特别强大。而且当你给予自己像我之前说的那些你可能没有得到的关注时，或者当你允许自己掌控一切、做决定时，它尤其强大。你并不总是需要做那个配合他人的人。
You don't always have to be the one who says yes. You know, in terms of how we do that, how we enact reparenting, make a big deal of yourself. Make a big deal of your achievements. Be allowed in like celebrating who you are and what you've achieved and what you're doing. in a way that perhaps you didn't as a child. You know, have the big birthday parties if that's what you want. Just literally speak out loud to yourself. Wow, I'm so proud of what I'm doing. What I'm doing right now is a big deal. I'm making an impact that is visible. I'm impressive. Remember, you are the parent now. So what you always wanted to hear as a middle child, but that you didn't
你并不总是需要做那个说“好”的人。你知道，就我们如何做到这一点、如何实施重新育儿而言，把你自己当回事。重视你自己的成就。允许自己庆祝你是谁、你取得了什么成就以及你正在做什么，以一种你在小时候可能没有做过的方式。你知道，如果那是你想要的，就办盛大的生日派对。大声对自己说。哇，我为自己正在做的事情感到骄傲。我现在做的事情是一件大事。我正在产生肉眼可见的影响。我很厉害。记住，你现在是父母了。所以，你一直希望作为中间孩子听到的话，但你却没有
receive is now something that you can provide yourself. Another way to re-parent yourself as the middle child is to not always be the one in the middle. Consciously make the decision to be the one on the outside, not be the one who has to mediate. If your siblings are fighting or your roommates or your parents or your parents and your siblings, whoever it is, you don't have to fix it even if every fiber in your body is screaming to get involved. You don't have to allow any of that to take up mental real estate. You don't have to think about what the best thing is to say to make both people happy. Just let people be messy. Let them have their problems. That also involves having strong boundaries. If there is a pattern of like two of your siblings or two people you know continuously
收到的话，现在你可以自己提供给自己了。作为中间孩子，重新育儿的另一种方法是，不要总是做那个居于中间的人。有意识地做出决定，做一个置身事外的人，而不是那个必须去调解的人。如果你的兄弟姐妹在吵架，或者你的室友、你的父母、或者是你的父母和兄弟姐妹，无论那是谁，你都不必去修复它，即使你身体里的每一个细胞都在尖叫着想要插手。你不需要让任何这些事情占用你的精神资源。你不需要去想说什么才是让双方都高兴的最好方法。随他们一团糟吧。让他们去面对他们的问题。这也包括设定强大的边界。如果存在这样一种模式，比如你的两个兄弟姐妹或你认识的两个人持续不断地
fighting and continuously getting you involved, just you really at some point you're to say, I'm sorry, that's not my job anymore. To mediate your conflicts, that is not my job. That is not all I'm worth, you guys can stay angry at each other because you chose to be angry at each other, not because I didn't help, not because I wasn't there, this is your choice, these are your actions, this isn't on me. I think that's a hard one to learn, especially when you do have that instinct to tend to want to fix things and resolve the conflict, but you're prioritizing yourself now. That's the whole deal. That's the whole goal. That's what we're after. Prioritizing yourself, even when you feel selfish. One final beautiful way to re-parent is to focus on what makes you
争吵并且不断把你卷入其中，你真的在某个时刻要说，对不起，那不再是我的工作了。去调解你们的冲突，那不是我的工作。那不是我全部的价值，你们可以继续生彼此的气，因为你们选择生彼此的气，而不是因为我没有帮忙，不是因为我不在场，这是你们的选择，这是你们的行为，这不怪我。我认为这是很难学会的一课，特别是当你确实有那种倾向于去修复事情和解决冲突的本能时，但你现在正在把你自己放在第一位。这就是全部的重点。这就是终极目标。这就是我们所追求的。把你自己放在第一位，即使你觉得自己很自私。重新育儿的最后一个美好的方法是，专注于是什么让你
special in the family and also in your life. You know, look at each member, look at each member of your family, notice how they're different, why they're different, their strengths, their weaknesses, and do the same for yourself. You have an identity in the family. You are probably the best at a lot of things and you do deserve praise and you do deserve appreciation and you do deserve appreciation and attention for all of that and you deserve to take up space in your family and to say, this is what I want, and I'm proud of myself, and I'm doing great things. And you can definitely bring that up with your family. Bring it up, be like, I really want to be appreciated more.
在家庭中乃至在你的生活中变得特别。你知道的，看着每一个成员，看着你家庭中的每一个成员，注意他们是如何不同的，为什么不同，他们的优势，他们的劣势，并为你自己也这样做。你在家庭中拥有一个身份。你在很多事情上可能都是最好的，你也确实值得赞扬，你也确实值得为所有这一切获得欣赏、关注和赏识，并且你值得在你的家庭中占据一席之地，并说：这就是我想要的，我为自己感到骄傲，我正在做伟大的事情。你绝对可以把这件事和你的家庭提出来。提出来，就好像：我真的很想得到更多的欣赏。
I want you guys to see what I'm doing. I don't want to be the one who always has to cooperate. I don't want to be the one in the middle. You can also choose not to do that. I think that is totally up to you if you think the response from your parents or from your siblings is not going to be a positive one. whatever is going to be best for you because I think that often the middle child is always forced to accommodate what's going to be best for others. We want to flip that script. What is best for you
我希望你们能看到我在做什么。我不想总是那个不得不配合的人。我不想做那个夹在中间的人。你也可以选择不这么做。我认为这完全取决于你，如果你认为来自父母或兄弟姐妹的反应不会是积极的话。做任何对你来说最好的事情，因为我认为中间的孩子总是被迫去适应对别人最好的事情。我们想要打破这种常规。什么对你来说才是最好的
now? As an adult, as someone who is independent and free, what are you going to keep doing to make sure that you get what you need from your life? You get to have a say. You get to do what you want to do. You don't have to be the mediator. You get to be as social, as introverted as whatever it is that you want. How are you going to make that happen? I really do have a lot of love for my middle children. I think that they're pretty amazing. As an elder's daughter, I'm always trying to impress my middle sister. Like, I'm always trying to be like, hey, do you like me? Now that we're a little bit older, like, do you still think I'm cool? And she's just so laid back. And I'm like, fuck, I'm really jealous. I'm really jealous of that. So you get a lot to be grateful for, a lot to be grateful for,
现在？作为一个成年人，作为一个独立和自由的人，你将继续做什么来确保你从生活中得到你需要的东西？你有发言权。你可以做你想做的事。你不必成为调解人。你可以变得像你想要的那么健谈、那么内向或无论什么样。你将如何实现这一点？我确实对我的中间孩子们充满了爱。我认为他们相当了不起。作为大女儿，我总是试图给我二姐留下深刻印象。比如，我总是试图表现得像，嘿，你喜欢我吗？现在我们稍微大了一点，比如，你还觉得我很酷吗？而她却那么随性。而我就想，操，我真的很嫉妒。我真的很嫉妒这一点。所以你有很多值得感激的事情，有很多值得感激的事情，
sorry. So I really hope that you learned something from this episode. Thank you for being patient with me. I know a lot of you have requested it over the last year and here you go. Hopefully it's everything that you wanted from it. Hopefully there was some cool facts that you can take away into conversations and say, hey, maybe I'm the way I am because of this and this is the study that tells me that and whatever, whatever it is. So thank you for listening. Make sure that if you haven't already, you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening, make sure that you are following along. And if you want to pre-order my book, the link will be in the description of this episode. Thank you to all of those of you who have already done so.
抱歉。所以我真的希望你从这期节目中学到了一些东西。谢谢你的耐心。我知道你们很多人在过去的一年里都要求过这个，现在它来了。希望它满足了你对它的一切期望。希望有一些很酷的事实，你可以带到谈话中去说，嘿，也许我之所以是现在的我，是因为这个，这就是告诉我这一点的研究，无论如何，无论那是什么。所以谢谢你的收听。如果你还没有这样做的话，请确保在苹果播客、Spotify或你正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，确保你一直在关注。如果你想预订我的书，链接将在本期节目的简介中。谢谢所有已经这样做的人。
It really made my week to see you all getting behind it. If you have episode suggestions, we also love to hear them. This was an episode suggestion. So I do love hearing from you about topics that we haven't yet covered. You can DM me at That Psychology Podcast. and also follow us over there. And until next time, be kind, stay safe, be gentle with yourself,
看到你们所有人都在支持它，这真的让我这一周都过得很开心。如果你有节目建议，我们也喜欢听。这是一位听众的建议。所以我真的很喜欢听你们谈论我们尚未涵盖的主题。你可以在“That Psychology Podcast”私信我，并在那里关注我们。直到下一次，保持善良，保持安全，对你自己温柔一点，
and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《以防万一》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而这些对话在其他地方真的不安全，但你正在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be placed, with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHare radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who been through the same thing.
有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容侵犯的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，美国广播公司《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰奇尼（Michael Ranchini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed I will be his last target.
成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他不会轻易逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。